you know how they say that there's um
it's it's not just homeschooling but
just like Catholic girls and so on just
because like there's moral you're
forbidden to do certain things like
there's a kind of liberating feeling of
saying
like basically rediscovering yourself
where he's covering your freedom by
doing just
uh diving head in head first into
sexuality into your own sexuality is
there some aspect of that yeah
absolutely to some degree I think that
like people kind of model it slightly
wrong like I think there's a truth to it
but when I first got out of the house
for me Freedom was like going outside at
2AM yeah or like eating chocolate you
know on days that I previously wasn't
allowed to eat chocolate like that was
like a really intense expression of
rebellion for me and I think people like
don't think of this like like I got out
a lot of my like intense Rebellion
through things that people don't
typically consider to be rebellious at
all sure like I wore a bikini yeah
insane uh I just like walked around in
it and like
I can do this yeah
and so like the this was most of that
emotional processing for me
um and I took a couple years from
leaving home and all of that
conservative culture into doing sex work
in in the meantime I was I did try
having sex with a lot of people but this
was mainly because I didn't know what
the Norms were I didn't really
understand I was just like okay take
things logically take things one step at
a time and I'm like okay if the whole
previous set about like how I'm not
supposed to kiss somebody until the
altar of marriage if that's not the way
that things are supposed to go then what
is the way things are supposed to go and
I was like well if I am aroused I should
go have sex with someone right is there
any reason not to no so I went I just I
would go around asking random people to
have sex with me did you have any peer
pressure saying like that's not good or
that is good or like any did you feel
any currents of society in any direction
it's probably are you independently just
thinking like for from first principles
I think I mean like I'm not saying it
was a totally a clean thing I'm sure
that I was experiencing Society telling
me this is bad but you have to know like
I wasn't watching normal movies when I
was a teen like we watched Christian
movies we are the stuff that we watched
was filtered like I watched the Titanic
and I had no idea that Jack and Rose had
sex because it was put through uh
filtered wait did they yeah they went
and you know he painted her naked and
yeah yeah there's a scene in a car
cars and storage and these there's a
hand I watched it again later and I was
like I don't know what the sex scene
well maybe were you also put through uh
maybe it's the filter I see like did the
couple in the notebook also have sex
because maybe for romantic movies I
focus on the romance
maybe right and the sex scenes are
always like weirdly filmed in these yeah
because it's never I mean
it doesn't it feels more like romance
and sex
I guess that's the main focus of this
site yeah yeah that makes sense yeah
anyway so they had sex it's good to know
they did I'll go back and and watch now
you have your own filter on your brain
and once you realize that there are some
um like the foundation of your beliefs
were wrong then everything might be
wrong and you're kind of just doing yeah
principles basically and again like not
totally separate from culture but also I
think in general I also have a
predisposition to just be like you know
[__] what culture tells you just figure
out what's right for you and do it and
so that mixed with you know the figuring
things out from first principles I did
eventually figure out that I didn't like
having casual sex with just anybody
quite as much so I stopped that but it
took me a while to figure that out
what's the negative of casual sex it's
just like not good I mean the
chemistry you have with someone better
then then it can be a lot nicer but I
wasn't doing that I was just like
somebody I met and I'm like you seem
kind of cute okay like I didn't bother
to try and develop just any chemistry I
mean I didn't chemistry even outside of
sex just chemistry like human chemistry
like a big conversation yeah okay I
would I would I'm it's like kind of
cringy but I would like I would like
walk up to guys or send them messages
like would you like to have coitus is
what I would say you would say coitus I
said that
I mean it's kind of it's kind of cute in
a way I mean yeah it's a girl asking you
to get laid so they probably didn't care
that much
I'm saying that like I had a lot of
rebellion out of my system by the time I
started sex work yeah
um so like for me like maybe I'm sure it
was somehow related because we were
extremely sexually repressed growing up
I remember the day I learned I had a
vagina which was absolutely horrifying
uh do not recommend figuring out you
have another orifice in your body
um but like do you want to share the
process of you figuring out that you had
a vagina or he told me I had a vagina oh
like intellectually like there was
somebody said you have your vagina
vagina yeah and that was horrifying to
you yeah
I didn't know I had because you weren't
supposed to ever like touch or look at
yourself ever so I never did it was
really disgusting
and so I had no idea that what was going
on in my genital region and so one day
my mom sat me down I think it was like
nine or ten
and she was like you have a there's
another what
and you're going to bleed out of it is
what she told me well you're gonna bleed
out of it for a while and I was like
what the [__] mom
I didn't know the word [__] was but I
would have said that if I had known when
did you first learn the word [__] oh I
think I learned it when I was at a
playground and it was written somewhere
and I read it out loud and then a kid
next to me started giggling uh-huh did
you ever did you say [__] again for a
while no I think the next episode I I
swore the first time I was 18.
like intentionally said a swear word
when I was 18. did you feel good I was
like really nervous I was like nervous
oh I mean [__] pretty good yeah it
[__] pretty good yeah